all right let's now turn to a rising
artist tribute to Street vendors in Los
Angeles Hedy Torres wants to keep their
contribution to the city's food culture
from fading into the urban background
instead they pop off the canvas and her
portraits have caught the eyes of A-list
celebrities this morning Taurus tells
Lilia Luciano why this work is so
personal for her
along one of downtown Los Angeles's
busiest intersections a familiar scene
the often overlooked street vendor
a fixture of the neighborhood Guadalupe
Faithfully set up shop on sidewalks
selling hot dogs five dollars a piece
five days a week for over 20 years
for artist Harry Torres
honoring La Street vendors is an ovation
to hard work and a nod to the staple of
the city that are these mobile Merchants
you go everywhere and you see Street
vendors and they make the Landscapes of
Los Angeles she weaves her subjects
backstory into her work
etching words into the backdrop of The
Smiling entrepreneurs who pop up on the
brightly painted canvas some of them
actually have kids who are going to
University now and I'm a medium to share
their stories and also honoring them
with my art it's not just her passion
it's part of her story Doris's parents
proudly sold hot dogs on the street in
Colima Mexico and so did she so at 12
years old you are Street vending yeah
selling hot dog I was going to school
but my responsibility after school was
doing my homework and help my parents I
didn't understand that until later that
they taught me how to make money when
she moved to the the U.S at 18 the sight
and smell of Street vending were welcome
reminders of home and I thought that it
would be nice to actually have a
business as a street vendor I thought it
was going to be as easy as it is in
Mexico but it was not easy a lot of like
challenges a lot of people harassing you
it was a rough introduction but it gave
her a leg up in a new city and got her
saving for college where she eventually
earned a master's degree in art from Cal
State Northridge now the 34 year old's
work isn't contained to art shows
they're downtown on the side of city
buses and within the collection of
a-listers like Jennifer Lopez and I saw
by Netflix I'm like whoa let's win
Affleck but her work does more than
Adorn it Advocates
as a accountant because we are
supporting the economy the system that
value was recently acknowledged when
California's governor Gavin Newsom
signed a bill modernizing the state's
retail food code allowing food vendors
greater access to permits a reform that
will ease work for one of torres's
latest subjects Guadalupe gracias
Decades of selling allowed the proud
mother of four to send all of her
children to college
ah
okay
from selling to painting to celebrating
Street vendors on canvas Torres has come
full circle if you're having a bad day
views can stop get the fruit get a Tamal
get a champurrado that's where we are
there to create a Smiles on people
with great food they're a part of the
tapestry of Los Angeles and a very
important thread carefully woven into
her life too
entrepreneur signs a kid is that you
learn how to wait
patiently for the things to come your
way for CBS mornings I'm Lilia Luciano
in Los Angeles
thank you Lilia don't you want to go
there I know food and great art I love
that Jennifer Lopez shows up you think
okay is that that halfway yeah it is
about halfway there at Dunkin Donuts
apparently nice very nice very cool